hi my name is Luka from local imperio
comm and today we're going to talk about
love a few weeks ago I was sitting at a
table and attending event and all of a
sudden someone asked me a very peculiar
question we were talking about language
learning and it turned out that I speak
a few languages myself and it had some
foreign partners and this girl asked me
do you pick up girls to learn languages
or do you learn languages to pick up
girls and I had bit that the question
kind of caught me off guard and got me
thinking at the same time so I've been
thinking about my experiences and the
lessons I've learned and here it is I
wanted to share them with you today
the very first important lesson that
I've learned when it comes to speaking
foreign languages with your foreign
partner is that you should at least
speak their language at an intermediate
level I still remember that when I met
my ex French girlfriend I spoke French
relatively well and the same happened
with my ex Russian girlfriend and I am
sure that if I hadn't spoken those
languages at a good level I would have
never spoken or practiced these
languages because we would have reversed
we would have resorted to go figure
English and I've learned that once you
start a relationship in a specific
language that relationship solidifies
and coalesces around the language is
really difficult to change languages
switch languages down the line so the
first lesson I've learned is learn
languages because the more languages you
learn the more opportunities you you
have you never know maybe today you're
going to stumble upon a girl or a guy
who speaks the language you're learning
and remember every language you learn
makes you closer to millions of people
potentially
the second important lesson I've learned
is that language learning doesn't happen
automatically in general and doesn't
happen automatically even if you have a
partner you still have to put in the
effort so you might be thinking that
since you have a partner you might want
to get every chance you get to practice
that language with her or with him but
your partner is your love partner you
share love with them not you know it's
not your he or she is not your language
partner so you have to make a compromise
you have to learn but you don't have to
pester them with too many questions
because otherwise they're going to get -
they're gonna get the idea that you are
there to use them how to do that my
advice is to keep learning on your own
get massive input get into the habit of
listening reading and then also on top
of that you have the chance of
practicing language languages for
example on the internet or with other
friends that's then that's great then
the cherry on the cake is to practice
with your with your partner but that's
the cherry on the cake you should do the
bulk of the work yourself the third
lesson I've learned is that when it
comes to having a foreign partner you
get your fair share of embarrassing
moments of misunderstandings of misusing
words or saying one word thinking that
you're saying something while you're
saying something else meet the parents
meet the circle of friends this is all
part of the beautiful adventure of
having a foreign girlfriend or a foreign
boyfriend so I've had my fair share of
embarrassing moments but I accept them
and I know that this is all part of this
beautiful trip that is a language
learning and getting to know foreign
cultures and foreign people so here you
have it I hope that this was useful if
you have a tandem foreign boyfriend
or girlfriend please share your stories
your everything ranging from
embarrassing situations to
lovely moments with your partner's
families and and friends you can click
in the description box to check on the
link to an article that have written
about this where I share my very
personal stories and in particular my
first kiss in Ireland and how a language
learning played a huge role especially
speaking English with an American accent
made all the difference
[Music]
[Music]